[Music]
good morning it's great to see everybody
here hi I'm Lucas Bergstrom product
manager for Android architecture
components and before I get started I'm
curious how many of you were here last
year when we announced architecture
components for the first time awesome
ok this is a much bigger venue so that's
actually a decent percentage when we did
launch architectural components last
year we were doing something sort of
different for us for the first time we
were offering explicit guidance and how
to architect your app and giving you
components letting you do that and
frankly for us it was a little bit of a
journey into the unknown so twelve
months in let's check in on how we're
doing so we've shipped 26 releases since
May last year so we've been constantly
iterating and improving on the course at
our architecture components in the sign
of any healthy open-source project we
have a very active issue tracker I'd
like to thank everybody that's taken
time to file a feature request or even a
bug and we've closed a lot of those we
launched a major new library paging
which is now stable and we'll talk a
little bit more about today and I'm
pleased to say that based on our survey
data over half of you are using or
planning to use architecture components
and this survey was done only a few
months after we went stable so this data
is pretty out of date by now but I'm
pretty proud of the fact that only a few
months after launching to stable over
half of the Android developers we talked
to you were planning to use this stuff
but more importantly than any of this
you've told us that architecture
components actually make it easier for
you to build robust apps that having a
clear path on how to architect your app
and components that helped you realize
that has actually made a difference in
the real world and how you
your apps and we've heard that not just
once but we've heard that over and over
from a lot of developers that have taken
time to speak to us so architecture
components has grown and we're going to
continue to invest here this is
foundational we think for Android apps
going forward but not just are we
investing in architecture components but
this year with jetpack we're gonna take
that same approach that we took with
architecture components a blank sheet of
paper approach to how Android developer
experience should be and you know how we
can improve things for you and jetpack
is going to take that and apply that to
the rest of the developer API service
that we offer so now I'm going to turn
it over to eat to talk about what's new
and architecture components
[Applause]
thank you so we will talk about what we
have been doing in this last one year we
look at the existing libraries talk
about the improvements and also look at
the new shiny stuff paging navigation
and work manager let's start with life
cycles so we have ship life cycles in
the last IO but to better understand why
we have created this component let's go
to two years before in 2016 we did a
bunch of developer surveys and asked
developers what is the hardest part of
Android development and by far in the
list big surprise was lifecycle
management
we're wondering like what can be hard
about I've found rotating or user
switching applications this happens all
the time on Android Android is built for
this but if you look at the problem in
detail if you want to handle them
properly in your application you need to
understand these state graphs where well
and when these two are interleaved it
becomes very confusing so we have
created life cycles component to get rid
of these problems and it seems to be
working because many developers give us
testimonials were a group of problems
just disappeared from their applications
when they started using these libraries
another important change for life cycles
was one year ago we have introduced them
as an optional library but now they are
fundamental part of Android development
you don't need to do any additional
libraries to start using them now both
app compat activity and the fragment
class implement lifecycle owner out of
the box another interesting thing that
happened was the community adoption so
we ourselves create new api's that works
with life cycles but we do other people
doing the same in their libraries and
this is so much easier because already
app compat has these dependencies so you
can easily depend on them in your
libraries one great example of this is
the auto dispose library from uber so if
you are using rx Java but you
the automatic lifecycle management you
can just add this Auto this force come
to your stream give it a lifecycle and
it will manage the subscription for you
for free now working on these things you
also discovered more problems we have
one of them is the Frank Mass we have
life cycle now Frank mass is a very
complicated life cycle let's look at an
example so if you have a fragment that
when it's created is observing a live
data I go through the regular creation
we create a wave for it and it goes to
the resume state at this point if you
have new values in your life data your
UI will start displaying them everything
works fine later on user hits a button
so you want to detach this fragment
because they are going to another
fragment and we're going to stop that
fragment but once the fragment is
stopped we don't need to weave for it we
would like to reclaim those resources so
we destroy the wheel later on user hits
the back button you go back to the
previous fragment we reattach it now
because we have destroyed the wheel we
need to create a new one we go ahead and
do it but it's a brand new wheel it goes
through the regular creation cycle and
now we have a Bart this nivea will never
resume the state of that live data
because you are using the fragments
lifecycle to observe it so we don't have
any reason to really dispatch the same
value of course the flight data receives
a new value do you I will be updated but
it's kind of too late because on
recreate you don't your UI has a bad
state now this left you with two options
you would either subscribe in oncreate
it looks very clean one-time setup but
it will fail if you recreate the view so
you needed to manually update the wheel
all your subscribing or create view
which handles in creation but now you
have double subscriptions that you need
to remove you lose the automatic
lifecycle management so the problem here
is that Frank may have not one but two
life cycles and we have decided to
embrace it and give the fragment view
its own life cycle so now start
support library 28 or Android X
fragments 1.0 while observing a live
data you can specify the real life cycle
and if the so while you're observing if
it is about the wheel you use the view
life cycle otherwise use the fragment
life cycle and we manage the
subscription for you for free okay data
mining so when we started to look at our
offerings as part of JPEG we and decided
to move data binding as part of
architecture components if you're not
already using data binding data binding
is our solution for boilerplate free you
eyes so if you're an object like this in
your application in your binding layers
you can reference the fees in your
object and we take care of updating the
UI for you in data binding 3.1 we have
added native support for live data so if
you're a V model like this which has a
live date of a user and if you pass it
as a parameter to your binding you can
use that live data as if it's a regular
field in your binding expressions data
binding will understand that is live
data and generate the correct code
unfortunately this is not enough for it
to observe it because data binding
doesn't have a life cycle to fix it when
you get your binding instance you just
tell it which life cycle it should use
it will start observing the light data I
keep itself up to date you don't need to
write any code for this
we also rewritten parts of the data
binding compiler to be a lot more
incremental so if you have a project
with multiple modules it's going to
compile a lot faster we are also working
on making the compilation even more
incremental but then I finish yet this
new compiler also gave us the able to
support instant tabs now you can use
data binding in the future modules of
your instant ABS okay group my favorite
architecture confidence
so Ruby server solution for object
mapping that finds the gap between the
SQLite and your Java or Kotlin code one
important change we did in room 1.1 was
the support for better multi-threading
so if you're losing one room 1.0 and you
if you have one threat that's trying to
exert a lot of data into the database
and you have another threat that's
trying to read data while the right is
executing your read will be blocked and
it can only execute after the right is
complete in room 1.1 with the right a
logging they can run in parallel now and
another nice feature of this thing your
writes run a lot faster than before best
part of this change you don't need to do
anything to take advantage of this if
the device is running jelly bean or
newer and it's not a low memory device
we are going to enable writer logging
for free okay another important addition
to room was the support for row carry
but to better understand why we needed
row query let's talk about the query
annotation now when you're using room
you can specify your SQL query in this
annotation you can use the name bind
parameters you could pass those
parameters as regular function arguments
you can tell the rule what to return the
best part of this setup is that room is
going to validate all of this at compile
time so if there's a mistake in your
query if your parameters doesn't measure
what you try to return doesn't make
sense it's going to fail the compilation
and let you know what is wrong now this
is all cool except what if you don't
know the query at compile time but if
you're writing a real estate application
by user can search the houses with a
price maybe they want to specify a
number of bedrooms bathrooms whether it
has a yard if you needed to query a
method for each variation of this that
will be impossible to maintain so what
you do in this case is you create to be
a query at runtime based on the options
user provided and you prepare the
arguments for that query now you obtain
an instance of the room database and use
this query method to get the result so
far so good
the problem with this approach is that
it returns your cursor who was the
cursor your
to get the list of houses so this looks
like a failure of the library has
decided to introduce Rockwell annotation
it looks very similar to query except
instead of specifying the query in the
annotation you pass it as a parameter to
the function and then you tell us what
you want us to return now here room
cannot relate that query anymore so it's
kind of you promised us to send the
right query and we'll take care of it
once you have that if you go back to our
previous example we can get an instance
of our dowel now we need to merge our
parameters and the query in this simple
SQLite query class which is basic data
holder and then you compress it to the
dog and get the list of houses normal
cursors no more boilerplate code ok
paging so Beijing is our solution for
laser loading in recycle area but to
better understand why we develop this
component or to go through an example so
you have a list like this is really
common every single application has this
user can scroll but you know it actually
represents a much larger list than
what's on screen and if you're an
application like Twitter for instance
it's a really long list so you probably
cannot fit it in memory and is also very
inefficient to load all of it so what
you will do is you would keep some of it
in memory the rest of it in database and
you also have your server component
where you pull this data from now this
is actually very hard to implement
properly that's why we have created the
paging library to make this common flows
very easy and efficient to implement
paging Bible comes with a page this
class which is an actual Java list
implementation but it works with a data
source
every time you access the items in the
pages it pulls data from the data source
lazily so if user Scrolls you need more
data it just brings them more data now
let's look at how we can get an instance
of these classes it's actually super
easy if you are using room
so room or didn't knows how to create a
data service it's a great example of how
these architecture components work very
well together so you can just tell the
room to return you a data source or a
data source Factory in this case I'm
using a data source Factory because data
is something that changes and each data
source represents a snapshot so we need
a factory so that we can create new data
sources and database changes once you
have that you can use this live page
builder class paste the page size and
call build on it it's going to give you
a live data of page list of users this
is almost the same thing as live data of
list of users now in your activity or
fragment you would use this page this
adapter which is a recycling your
adapter that works with pages you would
observe the live data every time you
have any pages give it to the adapter
and inside your adapter you can just
call this get item function to obtain
the user object this is a super simple
code to write and we take care of all
the hard work of paging it lazily for
you now even though I've shown all those
examples with live data paging supports
our X Java out of the box so if you are
using our Xterra and you want that
observable of pages you can just get the
same Factory that room generates but
instead use the rx page this builder to
build your observable or flowable now
paging supports paging from the
databases I have shown here but it's
also supports paging from the network or
you can combine both database and the
network for the best user experience to
learn more about it please join mine
Chris Craig tomorrow at 2:30 in the
paging session all right more about foo
possibly some of the suspense about what
foo is is gone now but yeah when you
think about sort of core problems that
almost every app has to deal with in app
navigation has to be close to the top of
the list there right now the framework
doesn't really offer anything for you to
do anything for you use there other than
start activity
which for various reasons is not the
best option so that means that for
navigation there are a bunch of things
that you have to figure out on your own
and that range is from executing a
fragment transaction without throwing an
exception hopefully passing arguments
from place to place possibly even with
type safety if you can figure that out
testing the navigation is working and
that the right things are happening when
you navigate from place to place that
the making sure that the up and back
buttons work correctly and take the user
where they're supposed to go mapping
deep links to destinations in your app
and having that work and by the time
you've solved all these problems you've
typically gone one of two directions
you've either written 60% of a
navigation framework just for your app
or you've got a lot of error-prone
boilerplate so everywhere navigation
needs to happen you've got a bunch of
parallel lines of code that need to be
changed anytime the navigational
structure of the app changes and this is
all pretty brittle and can end up being
a headache and individually these
problems are pretty tractable but when
you compose them into a real-world
example so say that I have an item
screen in my app maybe a product screen
and that screen is accessible via deep
link but actually there are other pages
that you know if the user had navigated
here by opening the app from the home
screen they would have come via the home
screen the category screen and I want
the UP button to take them through those
screens rather than exiting the app
right so that means that if someone deep
links into the app I need to synthesize
these screens and add them to the back
stack but only on a deep lake and
talking to a third-party developer or he
said you know it's when you're in the
middle of writing code to do this you
know on any deep link into my app and
synthesize the back stack correctly you
start to feel like maybe this is a
failure of the framework and so that's
why we're really happy to be launching
navigation
and which is a both a runtime component
that performs navigation for you and a
visual tool that works with XML to
define the navigational structure of
your app and then you know allows you to
just navigate at runtime with a single
navigate call and so the kinds of things
that you're gonna get for free right
that you just simply need to define an
XML and then the navigation framework
will handle at runtime for you our
animations passing arguments in a type
safe way from place to place making sure
that up and back work correctly and
mapping deep links to various screens in
your app and last but not least no more
fragment transactions ever
so I'll show you a couple demos of this
in action the first one is just to kind
of give you an idea of what this all is
so we're looking at a set of fragment
Trent fragment destinations in my app
and I'm adding a new one and now I'm
creating an action and this action is
the thing that I'm actually going to
call it run time to go from place to
place and you can see that there are a
bunch of other options that we'll get
into more in the navigation talk but the
one thing I do want to show you in more
detail right now is the example we went
through before so this is a simplified
version of that where there isn't a
category screen we just have the home
screen and then the item screen but I'm
gonna right now configure this to both
have a deep link pointing at the item
screen and make sure that if someone
deep links into the app that they go to
the home screen first when they hit
upper back rather than just exiting the
app right away so first I'm just gonna
configure a deep link on this screen and
the curly braket said I'm gonna put
around item ID indicate that I want to
extract a variable there and pass it as
an argument into the item screen okay
and now that's ready to go and if I
compile run my app that'll just work and
navigate to the right destination now I
just set the home screen to the start
destination that means that it's the
hierarchical parent of all the other
screens in the graph so when someone
deep links into the item screen and then
hits up they're gonna go directly to
that home screen so now I can now I've
just solved in 30 seconds what would
have been a really terrible and
time-consuming task in Java or Kotlin
back in the old world so now I'm gonna
pass it off to eat to talk about work
manager I mean using navigation a couple
of weeks for some demos this feels like
magic so I hope you all liked it our
next like takes your component
it's work manager now work major is our
solution for deferrable granted
execution what I mean by this you're out
of actions on Android that you really
really want to do if user does something
for instance if user sighs so send a
tweet you want to send it now but if
there is no network connection you want
to send it as soon as device is
connected to the internet there's things
like uploading locks you may want to do
if the device is charging or you may
want to periodically sync your data with
your back-end now we know this is not a
new problem on Android and we had some
solutions for this we have introduced
jobscheduler
in lollipop and we have fireman's job to
switcher that back force
dysfunctionality in the devices which
has Google Play services and we also
have alarm manager for exact timing now
each of these has different behaviors
and different api's it becomes very hard
to implement as we have built work
manager that sits on top of them and
provides a much cleaner API with new
functionalities work major has two
simple concepts you have the workers
that execute these actions and you have
the work requests which trigger these
workers now if you want to look at the
sample worker this is basically all you
do you extend the worker cause you
implement one function they says do the
work and that function just needs to
return us what happened as a result of
that work so you can do whatever you do
and you returned resolved there's no
services no interns no bundles nothing
like that once we have the worker we
need to create a work request so you can
use this one-time work builder or
there's a product version of this one
you can specify the worker cost but now
you can also add constraints you can
tell it only run if there is network
connection if the device is charging or
you can specify a back of criteria so if
the worker is failing how should we
retry it you can also pass input
meters to these workers once you built
that work request you can get an
instance of work manager and nqe that
work manager will take care of executing
it one of the important distinctive
features of work manager is that it has
input and output semantics so your
workers can receive input but they can
also output some data you can observe
this data through work manager was
actually very useful to chain your
workers so imagine you have an
application where user picks an image
from their device then you want to some
run some image processing on that
picture and now once it's done you want
to upload it to your server now these
are two different units of work like you
can process the image maybe you want to
do it when the device is idle or you can
do it anytime but to upload it to a
server you need internet connection but
you don't want to wait the processing
for the internet relation because it
doesn't need it this is super easy to
implement in work manager so have two
different workers
they'll have single functionality one of
them does the image processing the other
one does the upload to server well
create a helper function that receives
an image file and creates the process in
which work requests so it prepares the
input just uses the same builder to
produce the request now we get that now
we wanted our network upload to wait for
the internet connection so we set a
constraint we say ok wait for internet
connection before trying to run this
work request and then create the upload
image were using that constraint once we
have them you can tell work manager ok
begin with the processing which work
once you are done then run the upload to
server work and then you in queue - both
of these as an atomic operation - the
work manager then your device can
restart anything can happen in between
we will take care of running the tool
you can also use this API excessively
like you could run image processing in
parallel the same way so if user pick
multiple photos you want to
all of them but upload it to server was
all off tomorrow none you can easily do
that with work manager we will just use
the same function or create three work
requests for each of the images user
picked we create the upload work in much
the same way we did before and then we
say okay begin with all these three work
items once all of them are done then run
the upload work and then you include it
as an atomic operation and it takes care
of running it another important feature
of work manager is that it is not just a
wrapper for job scheduler or 5s job
dispatcher it's actually an executor
itself so let's get why opportunistic
execution is important so if you an
application rail user can send an email
so user hits the send button you send
the job info to the job scheduler or to
the firebase job dispatcher and it will
eventually call you to execute it back
the problem here is that you don't know
how long it will take even if your
device kernel has network connection it
may take a couple of minutes for job
scheduler to call you back and you have
no control over it
you just don't know and it results in a
bad user experience to work around it
what you usually do is you also have
your own thread pool whenever user hits
and you try to run the same thing there
as well and you take care of the
duplicating random work minute when the
job scheduler calls you back if you are
using word manager you don't need to
think about it because when you send a
work request to the work manager it puts
it into its own database then it tells
job scheduler or whichever scheduler it
has on the device ok I need to be
invoked when these constraints are met
but it also checks those constraints
itself and if they're already ready it
will instantly start executing the job
and later on if job scheduler comes and
asks is the execute now work manager
knows whether it is executed or not and
handles the requests properly to learn
more about work manager please join us
today at five
thirty in the work manager session right
what's next okay so I think it's been a
pretty great year in Android app
development hopefully you agree we
launched the set of great new components
last year and we kept working on those
and iterating on those we've launched
three new major components work manager
and navigation and paging since then so
does that mean we're done
obviously not we have a lot more to do
and the first thing that we want to do
is we want to make architecture
components the default way that people
build Android apps and that doesn't mean
that it's going to be required but it
does mean that we want to make sure that
as many people as possible you know get
architecture components regardless of
how they get into into Android
development so that means that not only
are we going to be building more tools
like the navigation editor into Android
studio that are sort of architecture
components aware but we'll also be
adding more templates that include
things like view models so that you know
people starting a new project have the
easiest possible kind of on-ramp into
Android development and in terms of
libraries you know not only we're going
to be building more architecture
components and not only are we going to
be building in more of the kind of core
architecture components goodness like
lifecycle awareness into jetpack but we
want to look at other Google API as well
and see you know how we can make those
sort of our contextual components aware
so that for example if you're calling
another Google API that's asynchronous
right it already has that built in so
that you're kind of getting architecture
components benefits whether you know
you're using it or not and then finally
we've heard from everybody that you want
us to speak with a single voice you want
us to give clear and consistent guidance
so that means that in terms of education
and that means not just documentation
but it also means sample apps
code labs that all this stuff is going
to be refactor to kind of be built on
top of architecture components so that
whether you you know start with the
guide app architecture or you just
download a you know sample media player
app and to start customizing it that you
kind of regardless of what you're on
rampion Android development is that we
get you to the best possible place we
know that we still have some areas left
to address in the core and you could see
some of those here so this is just to
say that we are definitely not going to
stop investing in the original set of
architecture components and there's some
you know not just problem solving here
but some exciting stuff that we can do
around how can we make architecture
components as idiomatic and fun to use
as possible for people using Kotlin so
there's a lot to be done still in sort
of I think the core set of app
architecture and life cycle problem
areas so we'll keep working there but
beyond that I think you'll see something
interesting about our trajectory if we
look at all the components we've
launched the date so last year kind of
this set of architectural components was
you know these are relatively small
pieces relatively small api's that are
designed to be used in a lot of
different places in your app and then if
you look at room navigation work manager
these are much larger and richer api's
but they're still relatively sort of
self-contained right they solve a single
problem they do it really well
paging also solves a single problem and
solves it well but in this case we took
a very specific use case right so lazy
loading for recyclerview and we're
actually in this case orchestrating
multiple architecture components and
pieces of Jetpack to solve that problem
so paging is a little bit higher level
it's not just sort of here's your you
know object mapping layer right it
actually takes a very specific I know I
have or cycler view with more data that
I can fit in memory and uses multiple
pieces of architecture components to
make that as easy as possible and we
want to continue
to you know build more stuff like that
so not just or we're not just gonna keep
investing in the core areas of app
architecture and life cycle but we want
to start solving you know higher level
problems and you know make more and more
as easy as possible but I can't leave
today without thanking everybody that
helped us get here the reason that we
were able to have a really high quality
bar for architecture components was
because a lot of people many of whom are
here today we're really generous with
their time and that includes not just
filing issues on the issue tracker but
also you know testing pre-release
components having one-on-one
conversations with us to you know tell
you tell us what your biggest problem
areas with Android app development were
this has been critical to us and making
sure that we're kind of focusing on the
right problems and delivering solutions
ago that are gonna work for you so I
really have to thank everybody in the
community that's been so helpful
[Applause]
[Music]